this is a production of Cornell
University
it's a real pleasure to be here and
speaking with you all and it's really
exciting to see how many people have
have joined us today so so thank you all
for joining today what I'm going to be
talking about is really the the
landscape about uh what we know and what
we don't know about food waste and I'm
really gonna take you through the
Contemporary findings about how much
food we waste the impacts on the
environment and what we can do to help
reduce our food waste and
what I want to do is if we have time to
just follow up that discussion with some
um some things that we can do both at
the individual level but then also at
the system level and I'm not sure we
will have time to get to that but if we
do
um I would like to share that with you
so what I want to do is really make the
case that food waste is not just a
public health issue it's also an
environmental issue and I I also want to
stress that it's an economic issue too
it's an issue for affordability so I'm
going to be making those links
throughout this talk today
so as many of you probably know that 30
to up to 50 of the global food supply is
either lost or wasted every year and I I
want to talk a bit about that difference
between food loss and waste in just a
minute but that is enough food to feed
almost 2 billion people a 2100 calorie
diet per day and at the same time that
that is all happening
about 820 million people are
undernourished which is a little over
one-tenth of the global population
about a quarter of our fresh water 15 of
our crop land and 15 of our fertilizers
are used to produce food that ends up
being lost or wasted at some point
through the food system
and also as perhaps many of you will
know that in 2015 the United Nations
adopted sustainable development goals
and they adopted a pretty ambitious
Target for cutting food loss and waste
by half by year 2030. and just a few
years after that the USDA EPA and FDA
signed a formal agreement to pretty much
match that Target right to reduce food
loss and waste in the U.S by 50 by 2030.
so this is a global effort and also
specifically a a U.S effort
and what I'm going to be talking about
today is really setting the stage at the
global level but I a lot of my work is
really focused on the U.S level so I'm
going to start Broad and I'm going to
continue to kind of refine that into
what's happening at the consumer level
in the U.S
but like I promised we we need to make
this distinction between food loss and
waste and this is problematic because
there's different definitions that are
used and these different definitions
vary depending on the scientists that
are employing them the agencies right
that are defining them and it's
pampering our efforts to really measure
food loss and waste if we can't settle
on a firm definition for what that is
that also varies depending on the part
of the food system that we're referring
to so what I'm going to do is just to
lay out a definition of working
definition for each of these that we can
just refer to throughout the rest of
this of this talk this is also the
definition that I use in a lot of my
research there's definitely room for
improvement but I think that these are
pretty good working definitions so food
loss I think it's just easiest to think
of as the inedible portions of food that
are thrown away so you can think of pits
cores there's some seeds some peels that
are inedible or at least really really
challenging and pretty uncomfortable uh
if you if you do end up consuming them
and also don't taste too great so people
just end up not consuming things like
for example banana peels but for um
every time that I give a talk like this
I always get maybe a student or somebody
in the audience who who assures me that
they have actually consumed something
like a banana peel and it's not as
terrible as as we might think it is but
for for um the general audience I think
it's fair to say that those are broadly
considered inedible
and then food waste I think it's easiest
just to in pragmatic too to consider
that to be the edible portions of food
that are discarded and this is the
important point that they're discarded
for any reason
so this includes spilling the food at
home right this includes food that might
have
um you may not have purchased it spoiled
but then it's spoiled in your home so
this is not a matter of value judgment
it's not a matter of who's at fault but
just the fact of the matter is that at
one point this food was edible and now
it's no longer edible so there's other
reasons too some people just have a
distaste for for leftover food
people prefer food that's not blemished
even if it's perfectly edible and
perfectly safe to eat and the list
really goes on so this is just a quick
sampling of uh the reasons that food
ends up getting uh wasted
foreign
too that um although a lot of what we're
going to be talking about especially
later on in this talk is what's
happening at the consumer level food
waste and food loss is occurring at
every stage of the food system and the
food system as as you know a lot more
complex than I'm depicting here but I
think that this is just kind of a quick
schemata of what how food is lost and
how food is wasted at these kind of
three major stages of Agriculture
through the supply chain and at the
household level
so at the agricultural level there's
more data that's that's needed on this
but right now what we're saying is
there's more loss than there is waste
right and I won't go through each of the
um each of the reasons why food is lost
or wasted at each of these sectors just
in the interest of time but I've just
listed a few of the examples here in
each box just to give you an idea the
supply chain is just an over
generalization of many many different uh
sub-stages and processes in the food
system which I've included in the
footnotes but what we're seeing is there
appears to be about a similar amount of
food that's lost and a similar amount
that's wasted throughout the supply
chain
and then at the household level what
you're saying on the far right of your
screen and that darkest orange we're
seeing a lot more food that's wasted
than is lost
so here we're looking at the global
level right and we're looking at both
food loss and waste and we're looking at
different stages of the food system so
not actors right so we're not looking at
who is doing the waste but we're looking
at what part of the food system that
waste loss and waste is occurring so
what this is showing is that at the
household level this represents 61 at
the global level 61 of food that is lost
and wasted and this by the way is from a
a recent uh un environmental program
report that that came out just last year
about 26 of food loss and waste at the
global level is occurring at the food
service stage so places where typically
where you would be eating outside of the
home
and then where you're purchasing food
generally purchasing it for consumption
at home uh about 13 of that food loss
and waste is occurring so just think of
for example supermarkets
now
a lot of what we're interested in is not
just where in the food system this waste
is occurring but really who is doing
that waste and when we're looking at
stages we kind of miss out on on that
critical Nuance so this is why I'm
mentioning this is because if you
consider that consumers right are
responsible for the waste that occurs in
the household
consumers are also responsible for a
portion of this waste that occurs in the
food service sector right not not all of
it so some of that loss and waste well
because you eat out at a restaurant and
they've over stocked or they've
mismanaged some of their stock or maybe
some of their
um their delivery was spoiled
some of that is not the responsibility
of the consumer but some of it is and uh
approximately half of that is so
consumers are not always
taking home the the food that they're
not consuming on their plate for example
so this just shows that the um the
consumer
contribution to overall food loss and
waste is much bigger than what you're
seeing here it's much bigger than a 61
percent
now also sticking at this Global level
uh what we're seeing is that household
level food loss and waste appears to be
similar across countries uh by income
level
so if you are looking at the y-axis this
is kilograms of food loss and waste per
capita per year and on the x-axis this
is GDP uh per capita in thousands of
dollars
so you can see that there is really a
there's really no observable Trend you
would think that there would be you
would it's often thought that there
might be more waste that's occurring in
higher income countries and um the data
are still limited on that but this is
what we're saying this is the most
contemporary data that we're seeing at
the global level and we're saying that
there is no discernible Trend in uh in
food loss and waste by income uh across
countries at the country level right and
there's a few reasons for that that we
think that could be contributing to this
phenomenon of for one we see that lower
income countries there's a considerable
amount of waste that's occurring earlier
on in the food system right and this is
because of inadequate food storage
Technologies uh because of um
challenges in maintaining old storage in
logistical infrastructure in
in political management of resources but
we're seeing in higher income countries
a lot of that waste that's occurring in
the latter part of the food system right
so in the at the consumer level now it's
an open question right now about how
what this trend would look like in
within countries right so for example in
the U.S our higher income households
wasting more than lower income
households that right now is uh is an
open question there's some data that are
that are trickling in but right now we
just don't know yet uh exactly what the
demographic characteristics are of these
high or low wasting households or
individuals so that that really is an
area for um for Fruitful research to
come foreign
now I'm going to present just some of my
work interspersed uh into this this
presentation here and this is some work
that we had done a few years ago but
this is actually uh continued on in a
number of different ways
currently this is looking at consumer
food waste specifically and specifically
in the U.S so remember we started out
very broad looking at Food loss and
waste at the global level and we are all
throughout the food system and now we've
kind of honed in to waste specifically
at the consumer level specifically and
in the U.S
excuse me specifically
so what we're seeing is that on average
Americans are wasting it's a little bit
less than one pound of food per person
per day and this is about a quarter of
all of the food that's available for us
to consume and we're also seeing that
that healthier diets are associated with
greater amounts of food waste and this
appears to be largely driven by fruits
and vegetables so let me just walk you
through this so uh here this bar chart
on the left hand side of your screen on
the y-axis this represents daily per
capita food waste in grams
and in the x-axis this represents diet
quality so on the left the leftmost bar
this lightest color orange this
represents the lowest diet quality right
so the lowest adherence to say that U.S
dietary guidelines
and this this uh rightmost bar this
darkest orange represents the highest
diet quality right so this is a this is
on a scale from zero to a hundred with
zero being the worst and 100 being the
best diet quality that perfectly adheres
with the dietary guidelines for
Americans and so this bar right here
this horizontal Dash bar this is the
average so that's about 422 grams per
person per day and as you can see as we
move from left to right of this bar
chart we're seeing that as dye quality
increases
the amount of food waste also increases
and so this is a linear increase and
this um when we did this research this
was actually pretty surprising so we dug
a little bit deeper into this and what
we saw was when we look at the total
amount of food that's wasted we are
seeing and this is I'm referring to this
pie chart here on the right hand side of
your screen we're seeing that almost 40
percent by weight of that food that's
wasted is fruits and vegetables and
behind that about 17 is dairy behind
that 13 is meat and then grains and
sweeteners and beyond that we get into
very small proportions of total food
waste so this is largely driven by
fruits and vegetables which uh dominate
in healthier diets
and we're also interested in the
environmental impacts of this food waste
right and and also what I'll share with
you after this is how those
environmental impacts May uh vary
depending on your diet quality
so here what we're looking at is the
amount of harvested cropland that ends
up being wasted right and so this is
this is land that is used to produce
food that ends up being wasted by the
consumer so on the y-axis we're looking
at the percent of harvested crop land on
the x-axis this is our types of land
so total what we're seeing is about
seven percent about 30 million Acres of
crop land are used to produce food
that's eventually wasted but as you can
see that when we take a look at fruits
and vegetables we're seeing about 55 to
65 percent of our fruit and vegetable
land ends up being wasted
foreign
and here again what we're looking at is
how these environmental metrics of food
waste vary depending on diet quality so
again for each of these panels we have
uh diet quality as the x-axis going from
the lowest on the left to the highest
diet quality on the right and this first
panel is looking at crop plant right so
we're looking at on the y-axis million
Acres of cropland that are wasted every
year and what we can see is that as we
go from the lowest quality of the
highest diet quality we are seeing
actually a decrease in the amount of
crop land that ends up being wasted but
the picture looks different right when
we're looking at uh other metrics like
irrigation water and pesticides uh
irrigation water on this middle panel
you can see that as we go from lowest to
highest high quality
that's that amount of irrigation water
that we're wasting increases and we see
something similar with pesticides too as
we go from low to high diet quality we
see that the amount of pesticides that
end up being wasted on food increases as
well so this is surprising to to many
people too and we think well
it seems to be that fruits and
vegetables are largely responsible I I
don't want to over uh attribute it to
fruits and vegetables but 40 of that
waste is attributable to fruits and
vegetables uh and why is it though that
we are seeing less crop land that's
wasted as we increase fruit vegetable
intake but we're seeing more waste of
irrigation water and pesticides and that
is because fruits and vegetables are
part of a
a categorization that we use in in
agriculture that we refer to them as
specialty crops so fruits vegetables and
nuts and seeds and Specialty crops are
largely this is a little bit of a
generalization but it's a hopeful one I
think is that they're largely intensive
from
so they typically aren't requiring a lot
of problem but they're requiring a lot
of inputs right so we're talking about
irrigation water and agricultural
chemicals like fertilizers and
pesticides and you can just compare that
to our other category that we use which
is field crops so those field crops are
extensive right so we're growing them on
very large swaths of land and per unit
of land area they're not using as much
chemicals and irrigation one now on on
an absolute level right because we're
growing so much of them they do use a
lot but not on a per acre level so those
uh extensive crops those fuel crops are
grains typically grains and oil seeds
and feed grains
also uh forages
and we also see that the food waste in
the U.S accounts for as much greenhouse
gas emissions as approximately 33
million passenger vehicles and uh we are
embarking on some some more contemporary
research to bring this uh in line with
more contemporary data right now as we
speak
so her message is really that the
consumers should try to be doing two
things at the same time
one is improving their diet quality but
at the same time reducing their food
waste there is this uh idea that it's
out there and I engage in in many um
spirited discussions about this that we
uh
based on all of the uh the available
data I think it's pretty clear that we
need to be moving beyond this concept
that if we just improve our diet quality
that's necessarily going to be good for
the environment we see that that is the
case in in many cases but there's also
cases where um that doesn't pan out
there's many ways to eat an unhealthy
diet there's many ways to consume a diet
that's bad for the environment and the
reverse is true as well and they don't
always line up and I think we've been
um misled into thinking that if we just
do one of those things if we just eat a
healthier diet it's always going to be
better for the environment and what
happens is that leads to cases like this
that we consume healthier diets but
we're not aware that these healthy diets
because they
they include so many fruits and
vegetables and fruits and vegetables are
highly perishable and wasted in very
high amounts that that can sometimes
lead to the high amount of food waste
and the attendant environmental
consequences so we want to see that
people are doing both of these things at
the same time increasing healthy diet
right and also reducing the amount of
food that they waste
so this begs the question of why people
waste so much food and I'm just going to
point you to what I think is the most
important finding from this particular
table and that's what's highlighted in
the the bottom left and so people were
asked to estimate
um how many
um people right compared to the average
American uh how much food is wasted
right and so this is what people
reported that they waste less food than
70 excuse me 73 of people said that they
waste less food than the average
American right so three quarters of
people said that they wasted less food
than the average American
and that doesn't add up mathematically
right so what this tells you is that
people are underestimating the amount of
food that they're wasting they're
thinking that they're wasting less than
they actually are
so some common reasons uh that people
report uh discording food so the the two
highest reasons are a concern about food
poisoning and a desire to consume only
the the freshest foods and these are
valid concerns right but uh what we see
is that some of the the leading reasons
that people are discarding edible food
is because of a misunderstanding over
date labels so those are what we just
colloquially referred to as the
expiration dates on food and those are
not standardized at the federal level
with the exception of infant formula
those are not standardized at the
federal level this is done at a state
level which is the reason why you see
this hodgepodge of different
terminologies it's used so you see sell
by Best Buy freshest Buy sell before
best before and the list goes on and
consumers are
um perceiving these dates to mean the
absolute last day that this food is safe
to consume and really what these are
intending to mean is an approximate day
that you can use as a guideline for
freshness and really what we want is for
people to be using this information
in tandem with all of the other
information that consumers are able to
glean from Foods right so how does it
smell what does it taste like what does
it look like when did you buy it what
were the conditions that you bought it
under was it transported home safely was
it uh damaged along the way
and we really for people that have full
capacity of their sensory perceptions
right that are not immunocompromised
I recommend that people are using all of
the tools in their skill set to
determine whether that food is safe to
eat now if I for example have uh milk
and it's past the date label and it
hasn't been opened yet then I'll open it
I'll smell it I will maybe take a taste
of it I'll take a look at it
I will use that milk now not everybody
feels comfortable doing that and you
should definitely err on the side of
safety so if you are concerned about
whether the food is spoiled and again if
you have limited capacity for sensory
perceptions if you have
um if you're in an immunocompromised
State then you definitely want to err on
the side of safety but otherwise uh I'd
recommend that you use all the tools in
your tool kit to decide whether that
food is safe to consume now for me
personally if I had a milk that was
unopened and it was a month past the um
the date label I personally would decide
not to consume that I'm going to err on
the side of safety there but different
people are going to have different ways
of being able to discern that and
overall we do see people throwing away
perfectly edible food just because it's
just a day after the expiration date and
it is likely a safe to consume
people also say that they um they will
throw away food because they don't think
that it costs much money
at the same time and this is interesting
at the same time people also report that
uh they would
um one of the leading motivators to
reduce their food waste would be saving
money so this tells us that people
really are not aware of how much money
they are actually spending on food that
ends up being wasted so this was some uh
some work that that we had done uh just
a couple of years ago looking at the
amount of money that we're spending at
the consumer level on food that is both
lost and wasted
and what you're looking at here on the
uh y-axis this is the daily per capita
expenditure on food and we break that up
into all food that we're consuming and
also food that we're just consuming at
home the food that we're just consuming
away from home and then within each of
those bars we're also splitting that
into food that is inedible which is the
blue
food that's wasted which is in the green
and food that's actually consumed which
is in the red and as you can see the
total amount of money that we're
spending on food is approximately 13 per
person per day when we factor in the
amount of food that the amount of money
that we're spending on food away from
home
for a lot of people they may not realize
that we are spending about half of our
food Budget on food away from home and
for a lot of the uh reports on the
amount of money that we're spending on
food that additional cost on food away
from home is typically not represented
so this is much higher uh than people uh
are were previously aware when they were
only looking at the amount of food that
we're spending amount of money that
we're spending on food at home but take
a look at the amount of money that we're
spending on food from all sources right
we're saying that about 60 percent of
that is food that's actually consumed
the rest of that is wasted and inedible
so over a quarter of our food spending
actually is on food that ends up being
thrown away and you can see that as a
proportion of the amount of money that
we're spending on food at home and also
food away from home I'm just saying
approximately the same we're saying a
little over a quarter of that
expenditure is uh food and waste
and when we take a look at that over the
course of the Year we're seeing that
that's about thirteen hundred dollars uh
per person
so that is uh the annual cost on the
y-axis and on the x-axis we're looking
at Food waste in the left most bar that
red bar but then I think it's helpful to
compare against other uh other outlets
that we're spending money on right so
we're spending more money on food waste
than we are on vehicle gasoline on
clothing property taxes household
utilities uh and and that list goes on
so this does amount to a substantial
amount of money and I we think that this
is when we talk about certain levers for
Behavior change what we'd really like to
see is
um
uh this being incorporated into Behavior
change campaigns that we can make people
more aware of the amount of money that
they're spending on a wasted food and we
think that that would be one of the
drivers to help uh motivate people to
reduce their food waste
we also look at this by food group right
and we see that the uh the majority of
the amount of money that we're spending
on wasted food is meat and seafood which
are relatively expensive compared to
other food sources but we also see not
too far behind that we see about 30
percent of our food waste expenditure is
on fruits and vegetables followed by
grains sweets and Dairy
thank you
so what we also see is about 35 to just
over 40 percent of people say that
either they uh throw away food
um they feel
um uh comfortable with that because they
compost it right and so the the
implication is that that doesn't have an
environmental impact and others say too
again about 35 say that if they're not
concerned about the food that they
discard because it breaks down in the
landfill with the implication being that
um the environmental concerns are
mitigated
foreign so I I won't go into uh a lot of
detail on this because our next speaker
Mark Morgan is has expertise in these
issues and he's going to be uh
discussing some of the
um some of the more contemporary and
really exciting uh areas for mitigating
uh food waste and their environmental
impacts through landfilling uh but I'll
just say briefly uh that with composting
what you're looking at here in the top
right picture this is an at-home compost
this looks particularly well managed
where you have the new food scraps that
are deposited here and then you have
this looks to be almost fully composted
here on the left and they're just
transitioning from from one to the other
and then this is more of a municipal
composting facility but the point that I
want to be making here is that
composting is not environmentally
neutral composting is a much more
preferred strategy than just a
conventional means of just landfilling
but composting is also contributing to
this greenhouse gas cycle right and
again this um this does not mean that
composting is always very harmful for
the environment but it also doesn't mean
that it's neutral for the environment
either and we there is a recycling
that's going on but it is it's not a it
doesn't reach Net Zero so we still need
to be mindful of the amount of food that
we're even generating uh into the
compost cycle
now with landfilling and again our next
speaker is going to be speaking with
with much more expertise on this issue
but just as an introduction landfilling
is currently the the most common food
Waste Management strategy in the U.S uh
food waste represents over
one-fifth of uh the mass of the matter
in landfills and food waste is the third
largest source of methane emissions from
landfills and we see not just methane
emissions which are a particularly
potent greenhouse gas but we we also see
carbon dioxide emissions from the
aerobic digestion in landfills
so uh this is just to say that uh
composting is certainly not landfilling
uh are not a uh environmentally
beneficial or even neutral means of uh
of discarding food waste and uh the
people that are are feeling the the the
third and over in some cases 40 percent
of our um of our peers that are uh not
bothered by food waste because they feel
that it is uh being environmentally
mitigated in compost and landfilling uh
that that notion uh needs to be
corrected
and I find this this really helpful this
um Environmental Protection Agency food
recovery hierarchy this is just
providing us with just general framework
for how we should be prioritizing our
mitigation efforts around food loss and
food waste so our most preferred option
and this is something that we should
always keep in mind is not wasting in
the first place right so this is doing
what you can so that you're not putting
more food on your plate than you're
going to consume and if there is more
food on your plate then you can consume
to if possible to to find a way to to
store it safely so that you can consume
it later and the the list of those
options goes on but the the goal here is
to avoid wasting in the first place
uh you can see that next are uh donating
food that can only really be done in a
really uh meaningful way through uh
canned packaged Foods there are
absolutely ways to do that for fresh
fruits and vegetables it's just much
more common to do it for canned and
pre-packaged Foods because they have a
longer shelf life but they're absolutely
ways to do that for fresh fruits and
vegetables and those those creative ways
that that are being implemented right
now it's just we see that that's not
quite as common and obviously if you all
have waste on your plate
um for all intents and purposes that
really is not donatable right it's
really food that that is safe to consume
because it hasn't uh hasn't entered uh
entered your plate yet
there's options for for feeding that
food loss or waste to to animals that
would be largely for um for livestock uh
those options are are limited and I
don't think that we should really think
of our livestock as its primary means
for uh for disposing of our food waste
but there are some circumstances that
that's an option there's more creative
environmental excuse me industrial uses
so we're able to uh generate energy from
the methane that's emitted from uh from
certain
um landfills and also from manure
storage facilities uh that is not
Universal right but that is increasing
and then you can see towards the the
bottom of this list right we have
composting right and then we have
landfilling so we um we really do I
think this is we can critique this and
and in some cases I do think that we
should but overall I think that this is
a helpful framework that can help guide
us to where we're really putting most of
our efforts for reducing food loss and
waste and you can see that most of our
efforts really should be going to Source
reductions we're avoiding that waste in
the first place
so I actually uh do have a couple more
slides I think we have a a little bit of
time I'm just going to share with you uh
some of the options that we have for
reducing food waste at the individual
level and then also at the at the system
level there's a lot to say here so I
hope you'll you'll forgive me as I just
kind of give a surface level
introduction to this
so this was a report that came out uh
recently by the national academies of
Sciences and this was a high level
report where they provided some of their
recommendations for reducing food loss
and waste at the system level
so they organized this into different
Pathways right so this first pathway
that they're proposing is changing the
U.S food environment to help
um discourage waste by consumers so
they're proposing a whole range of ways
to do this
um you can see that harmonizing date
labeling is is among those
they are proposing innovation in the
food industry through linking the
private sector right so this is
governments at multiple levels at the
federal state local levels industry
levels that would be private but then
also at the academic sector right and
creating these where the the federal
government can come in is facilitating
these collaborations right so that we
can really push the needle on really
really creative ways to implement the
strategies at scale
the second pathway is really to empower
consumers right to reduce their food
waste so they're suggesting a national
Behavior change Campaign which would
include influencers for example and ways
to really reach populations say younger
populations that might not be otherwise
reached through what have become these
more conventional messaging techniques
through the federal government and
through uh state and local governments
and also engaging and developing these
methods for instructional and
experiential learning about food waste
literacy in Early Education
this third pathway right is leveraging
and then applying research findings and
Technology to support consumers right in
their efforts to reduce food waste so we
need more Federal investment and support
on measuring food waste right so how
exactly are we going to be measuring it
at the consumer level at the household
level at the municipal level and how are
we going to make those data available
for researchers
for scientists in both Academia in the
private sector and also in the public
sector to engage meaningfully with this
research and how are we going to also
promote the dissemination of those
research findings right open access
so there's many individual level
strategies I'm just going to highlight a
few of these out of the um the interest
of of the limited time that we have left
here uh one and this is something that I
had already talked about is just being
mindful that waste of food means wasted
money and remember that most people do
report that saving money is their
biggest motivator to reducing food waste
so increasing awareness not just about
how much food we're wasting but about
how much money we're spending on that
waste of food
uh other tips people can be more
Discerning about their use of coupons or
other discounts promotional techniques
that lead them into purchasing more food
than they actually need for themselves
or for the household right so this is
and this is this is uh empirical people
are reporting that people that they are
purchasing more food than they really
need because of these um these
reductions in price per unit that
they're actually getting for food and
that leads them to purchase more than
they're actually needing
foreign
this point too much more but using these
food labels these date labels as an
approximate diet for freshness rather
than the absolute uh last date that food
is safe to consume uh of course I want
to re-emphasize this uh that if you are
uh you know compromised or working with
an immunocompromised population or you
uh have any limitation in sensory
perception in your capacity for taste
smell or or any other sensory capacity
then you really should be airing on the
side of safety
there's also some some creative phone
apps that have been developed and more
and more coming out that help consumers
plan their food so their food purchases
food storage uh food cooking right to
minimize food waste and all of these not
all of these many of these are now
available uh for free for for download
on your phone
and I I will actually uh conclude that
this presentation now uh we we went
through a lot today
um and I thank you all for for joining
us and I thank you uh to to the Cornell
team for for inviting me and I welcome
any questions that you may have
foreign thank you so much Zach that was
a fantastic overview and and brought us
many different places in the whole
spectrum of the food system and food
waste
um I'm going to launch a poll for people
to fill out
um while we're doing the question and
answers
um
so if you could just toggle those
switches on the poll that would be great
um
I the first comment was I appreciate the
definition oops
um uh Kendall said I appreciate the
definitional challenge and also seeing
avoidable versus the unavoidable at the
YouTube
um useful distinction so right we all
have to get our vocabulary in line
Richard asks
um the U.S Imports a lot of fruit and
vegetables in off season where these
Imports included in your figures if not
since these are produced on non-us land
within the skew the crop Acres
yeah and thank you Kendall for for that
um that feedback and Richard thank you
for your question so this uh Imports
were included in our estimates uh we did
not disaggregate uh imports from uh food
that was uh grown domestically and you
you're absolutely right then when we
take when we look at metrics we attach
our food waste to metrics of
um of agricultural chemicals and
irrigation water and other agricultural
resources including cropland you're
right this is um we're really applying
metrics from the US right so uh this is
this is a data limitation issue this is
because of the um the massive amounts of
high quality data that we have in the
U.S and uh in other countries this is
this is not true of every country but we
don't have as high of of data quality uh
as uh in other countries as we do in the
U.S for agricultural resource use so
that limited to some extent and you're
absolutely right that that was a
limitation of our studies that one we
weren't able to disaggregate that but
then two is that it was a a
generalization about agricultural
resource use just because of the limited
data availability that we had
following up on that I'm going to ask a
personal question which was
you I think you said that fruit and
vegetables account for 40 of our waste
in the U.S
and so this is also an accounting thing
is that a function of the high water
content of the vegetables or are you so
are you doing it on pounds of product or
are you doing on a sort of proportion of
the nutritional or caloric intake on the
diet so I'm just wondering if your data
might be skewed just simply because of
moisture content as opposed to
proportion of the total diet does that
make sense
it's a great question so we we've looked
at it a few different ways what I
presented was uh that about almost 40
percent value was based on the um the
total weight so that would include
moisture but we've also analyzed it in
dry weight too and we we see uh we see a
similar ranking where fruits and
vegetables do come out on top but we see
that it's not quite 40 any longer but
still what we're looking at is somewhere
between say
25 to say 30 but fruits and vegetables
are still coming out uh very much on top
too okay
um Leslie asks um if you have old milk
but you boil it to make a latte or some
other drink will it be safe
I wouldn't use it as a way to
um I I personally I would just get new
milk if you think that your milk is is
spoiled I will say too though that um a
really good I'm not a registered
dietitian and I just want to be fair
that registered dietitians I've had many
many conversations about this issue and
the um it's been made very clear that
that
standard training with registered
dietitians and if there's any of you in
the audience you can correct me on this
but my understanding is that as part of
the standard training it is to really
pay close attention to those date labels
so I would uh you know I'm coming at
this from a research perspective not
from a clinical uh advice perspective
and if you have any uh clinical concerns
I would I would um I would speak to a
registered dietitian but for my own
personal perspective if I had milk that
I thought was
um was spoiled I would just get new milk
I I wouldn't uh I wouldn't boil it
to follow up on that I noticed in one of
your later slides uh you said that Dairy
food waste is only five percent of the
total and considering it's so perishable
like do you have any I mean there's lots
of wisdom embedded in that do you have
anything that could help inform the
other sectors because that was
notable
yeah it's surprising to us as well
um you know it was still ranked among
the top but yeah by by absolute amount
it was much smaller than than we had
anticipated as well and you know if we
weren't able to fully discern why that
was from from the data so that is
actually an area that we're interested
in exploring is what is it about a dairy
specifically compared to other animal
sourced foods like like meat and uh and
seafood why that would be uh less uh you
know it's it's possible that um and this
is just speculation but it's possible
that people are able to um it's much
more of a staple in the household and
people are much more able to buy the
specific amount of dairy that instant
different size containers that that they
can use you can also purchase your Dairy
from at least for fluid milk for
different um from different outlets for
example like convenience stores we can
just buy small amounts at a time but
what I think is really contributing to
that is the much longer shelf life that
you would have for processed dairy
products like cheese
so for fluid milk high perishability for
cheese uh they have much much longer
shelf life and and we think that if we
separated the cheese from the fluid milk
we would see a much different
contribution there
all right Peter do you want to ask your
questions
sure thanks thanks so much again
covering a lot of territory I'm just
curious if you I appreciate you sharing
some ideas about approaches for reducing
food waste I'm wondering if you know of
any research that's tried to quantify
the efficacy of any you know specific
kind of interventions or programs
um
and how effective they might be
especially like in relation to the
intensity of the effort
yeah it's a great question and something
that comes up a lot and I'll say too
that um well I'll um I'll just respond
to that question and then I'm afraid I I
will need to to depart
um I just have another engagement that I
need to attend to uh
there's um what was it was kind of this
has been an interesting Phenomenon with
food waste it was one of those issues
this also happened with the OBC epidemic
to some extent is that um we realized it
was a really big issue
um long after it became an issue right
so
these data uh arrived kind of on our
desk so to speak and we said holy cow
this is a really big issue and we look
back at the trends we're like this has
been an issue for a long time it hasn't
been fully addressed so what that means
is that right now what we're seeing is
we're seeing the funding for those
interventions a little bit late to the
game right but now it's really been you
know this is something that we hadn't
seen in just a few years ago now we're
seeing 10 million dollar grants being
awarded from the federal government to
address this food waste issue and there
are some um some great work that has
been geared up this is by no means
complete from my understanding been
geared up out of um Johns Hopkins
University from uh Ronnie Neff and
colleagues and also at Ohio State
University
and also there's been some work out of
um the UK on this issue and uh there's
been some initial findings on some
things that can be done at the household
level to help reduce food waste but
right now we're waiting for more of that
data to come in on is are those findings
stable across households of different
demographics and then what about when we
aggregate that to County state district
Province National level those data are
still are still coming in so I don't
have a firm uh a disaggregated answer
for you Peter but it's a great question
it's something that comes out a lot
comes up a lot and I am um just eagerly
awaiting uh that research that's
hopefully going to be coming out soon
from those groups that have landed these
these Mega projects
well thanks so much just a quick tie in
back to our theme of greenhouse gas
reductions
um
greenhouse gas mitigation uh it would
seem like if you're saving money then
the cost would be below zero right so I
think we should be also recognizing that
um even if there's a cost to the
intervention there might be a very low
or or benefit financially to reducing
food waste so in terms of greenhouse gas
reduction strategies it seems like this
should be getting far more attention
than it's getting
great
lovely final comment Peter thank you so
much Zach um for your time today
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu